it's early going to go find leave nation
that we work that's why I love doing
what I do I love be able to visit cities
level meet fans and help them one on one
[Music]
you
happy day three of our Philadelphia Palm
Springs spring is a spring trip it's
3:00 in the morning
I gotta taking it to the airport and
you're gonna join us for the day so
we're here in Philadelphia we came for a
two-day event with Satguru it's early
what what are we saying what are we
doing you know we did not sleep Nina
came at his Monday morning for us I'm
staying in Philadelphia to spend a day
with my fans meeting some bleep nation
then hitting the Palm Spring for clamor
con a YouTube event but Nina has to go
to work
she's got to work today so she's hit
enough 5:00 a.m. flight or something
like that back to Toronto and then gonna
go to work and then give the pick up
TiVo and spend a week good thing whoo
I'm gonna take me to the airport and
then come back home here to that home
not home come back to my to our place
and then sleep and then wake up and go
see my friends okay let's not make Nina
late let's go
[Music]
Eric and uh we're gonna miss you Nina
final message for believe nation safe
flight this for believe nation believe
safe flight I like it okay love you
[Music]
we're gonna miss you safe flight Nina
don't get in trouble on the airplane
okay this 408 a.m. I am NOT gonna film
anything no b-roll no airplane what are
we saying no highway I'm just gonna go
home and be as safe as I can on the road
so I'll see you guys when I get home
I made it guys I made it that was a
difficult ride difficult drive but I'm
back I'm going to see if I can get a
couple hours sleep wake up again and
head back out Philadelphia to meet the
belief nation family okay don't get too
excited
gotta sleep I will see you soon
you
it is amazing what a couple hours of
extra sleep will do for you I feel a
little bit more rested a little more
coherent I'm about to drive into
Philadelphia to do a meet-up at we work
with some believe nation fans and I'm
come to meet everybody I'm gonna take
you along and hopefully have some fun so
the Amazon box out there
hope it's okay last night was crazy rain
so we had to move these book we're
seeing above a bookstore
I had to move these books under the
under the cover so they didn't get too
wet anyway side notes we work
Philadelphia here we come
[Music]
all right parked made it out going to go
find believe nation that we work so I
put out a message to my audience saying
hey coming to Philly want to meet up who
wants to meet I got an entire day before
having to head to Palm Springs thought
it'd be better than flying home and then
flying back out so Michael who is that
we work said hey I'm willing to host so
let's put the event together so we're
meeting up at 10:00 a.m. at a local we
work and for those you don't know we
work as a company that does work sharing
for entrepreneurs
you can rent awesome you can rent an
office you can rent can rent a desk you
can rent whatever you need basically for
your business scale up scale down so
we're gonna meet there see how many
people show up always my favorite part
I'm excited I've attended to meet the
entrepreneurs here I can help here we go
found it we found it we found it we work
whoo-hoo let's go in
[Music]
all right just got out it is like 5:30
or something we met at 10:00 and went
all the way to 5:30 I didn't really
capture anything just a lot of emotional
moments to be honest talking business
talking personal talking relationships
then with a couple of them after we went
for lunch and we go for coffee and
that's why I love doing what I do I love
be able to visit cities love people to
meet fans and help them one-on-one it
really fills the soul probably spent
more time than I should have but just
makes me feel good knowing that the
ability to have an impact and help
people didn't film anything we took some
pictures we did a video interview
quickly on Instagram just because of the
sensitive nature of everything we're
going over I didn't feel as right to set
up a camera and start filming people but
we had about 10 people or so show up
amazing vibe awesome entrepreneurs here
in Philly just tons of fun and just
green horses why I do what I do I
probably could have had more of an ROI
doing business meetings meeting with big
brands going a day early the clamor con
connecting with people who could really
move my business forward but at the end
of the day this is what I really really
love doing what up at the end of day
this is what I really love doing see
even these guys you got a message guys
got a message all right
all good kind of work on that yeah at
the end of day I love what I do and when
you find that thing that you value more
than money you go all-in on it and I
promise you it's gonna end up paying off
so I'm gonna look for some food and then
head back to my Airbnb I haven't done
any work at all today so I need to get
doing some of that work maybe I can find
another Philly cheesesteak place
final-final dinner and then tomorrow
morning head off to climber calm
[Music]
alright gonna go for what's closed five
guys burger and fries I'm gonna burger
in a long time so here we go
[Music]
yeah look at the size of this burger I
haven't had a burger in a long time and
holy cow you know his double patties so
we got the burger who salted caramel
shake and french fries definitely gonna
be full after this one
after you cardio when I get home 30
minutes I promise to myself alright
couldn't quite finish still got some
fries left in a shake left feeling super
full but I'm gonna take it home with me
a little bit of a extra snack for when I
get back
next step gonna drive back to their B&B
relax bit pack up clean up I always like
leaving a place basically as clean as I
found it you know somebody's home it's a
lot of work cleaning up after people so
I like giving a little bit of extra
surprise when they come in and it looks
basically untouched so got some cleaning
up to do and then a little bit of work
get my cardio down go to sleep get ready
for Palm Springs tomorrow
one thing I love about the parking lots
is that when there's a free space is
little green light above it so look here
here it's great it's taken here it's
green well that's supposed to be taken
maybe didn't do a good job memorizing
that one so here it this one this one's
green empty spot there and so as you
drive in it gives you recommendations
they turn left there's five spots
available look for the green light and
usually there's a space there for you to
park so I'm gonna cool I like it
efficiency all right believe nation it
is bedtime I need to get up at 5:00 a.m.
at the latest tomorrow hobby I'm gonna
get up at 5:00 a.m. to head to my flight
to Palm Springs an amazing day in
Philadelphia thank you guys so much for
the hospitality I was expecting to do a
quick meeting and do a tour and maybe do
some work at a local coffee shop or
something and to wind up spending the
time with people from 10:00 in the
morning until 5:30 straight fantastic
conversations I'm so impressed
overwhelmed with the love here in
Philadelphia great people and some nice
entrepreneurs man ready to go off and do
amazing things so super blessed have
spent the time here excited to see what
these guys go and tomorrow
Palm Springs coming for you got
back-to-back flights I think I'm through
Denver not high percent sure but gonna
start to wind down for me need to sleep
5:00 a.m. wake-up call
believe believe thank you guys for
watching hopefully you're enjoying this
vlog series I apologize for not taking
you in behind the scenes to the actual
Satguru events and meetings that have
been having we'll see maybe tomorrow I
will do a better job videography and for
you guys next week thank you again for
the love I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love
belief in yourself and whatever your one
word is I'll see you soon